we're going to begin this hour with one
more look back at Russia's invasion of
Ukraine it was just over a year ago if
you can believe that one year ago and it
comes that from the CBS News crew that
was in Ukraine's capital and that very
first night of the war that senior
foreign correspondent Charlie dagada our
producer Justine Redmond and Camera
operator Abdi kadani they show us how
that first night unfolded and how
Vladimir Putin's decision to invade has
changed their lives in the lives of
millions of others
we didn't believe that it was going to
happen I didn't believe it was going to
happen
I didn't think he would start a war the
night before the invasion
I just had a hunch and I strolled down
to the cocktail bar at the hotel we were
staying and there were a bunch of
journalists talking to one another
saying is it going to happen isn't it
going to happen
and there was literally a piano player
playing
[Music]
and I told Justine to come down
and join me in a drink because I have a
pretty good feeling that this might be
the last time we have a drink
at this hotel Bar for a long time and at
this point it's about 2 A.M
and we knew
that this could be our last chance to
get any sleep for who knows how long
so everyone went to bed
and then about half an hour later my
phone rings so I had to go and wake
everyone up again like all right come on
everyone up everyone ready and I was
like oh my God this could actually
happen and to be honest with you it was
terrifying
way off in the distance I heard a series
of booms
and I've been in enough conflict zones
to know what that sound is I was like
okay that's it here we go
what we didn't realize
and really nobody did
was the scale of the invasion was it
going to be an attack an assault from
the East was it going to be massive
airstrikes is it going to be cruise
missiles and as it turned out it was all
of those things was I scared
there was one night when
um we were just finishing up our live
shots and Charlie's standing in front of
the camera
how was that and suddenly there's this
massive
flash of light like nothing we've ever
seen before and it was silent
or at least it was until about a good
10 seconds later or something when there
was this poor
now we have training when something like
that happens you get away from the
windows and balcony and you get low and
you get away from whatever that was
none of that training kicked in so I
decided to turn around and get a closer
look at what had just happened trying to
see if it was almost like something else
going on that would make sense of this
and I said
I was probably nuclear
and
we sort of laughed I was like but but
actually I'm not I'm not even kidding it
was scary at the time and we can laugh
about it now because nobody was killed
on the day
made a statement but the military was
going to start issuing Small Arms to All
Veterans and all volunteers and we saw
hundreds hundreds of people mostly men
streaming into the center
and walking out with guns and they
didn't have any training it's not like
they had marching orders they were just
getting guns
and
we looked at each other like this is
about to turn into the wild west at the
same time we're keeping our eye on the
emergency exit because if this is going
to get really bad we need to find out
where we can get to and when we're going
to jump and we had those conversations
are different the consequences of this
war felt like they could go much further
you know it could go as far as Europe it
could go beyond it could be a nuclear
war and so it really felt like we were
kind of on the cusp of something huge
that could reshape the world I don't
think it's
changed me as such but it's been
another
ongoing reminder of how precious life is
we've seen so many people with
absolutely tragic stories of loss
it's hard to
it's hard to see young children go
through these things and not
as a as a parent think of your own
children and
and just how heart-wrenching it is
when you witness that
repeatedly it does have an impact on
your life and has an impact on
your family it has an impact on
everything war is a terrible terrible
thing you come away from this always
feeling like you've
come this close to death and and so you
kind of come away feeling more grateful
to be alive and you know I think it's
that kind of coming to terms with your
own mortality again and again and again
I'm feeling like you've got away with it
that you know is a Hallmark of covering
stories like this and then you know we
walk away
when the people you know the victims
can't
wow it's so interesting to hear their
perspective I think Charlie sums it up
nicely when he says war is a terrible
terrible terrible thing and it affects
so many people on so many different
levels it's interesting to hear their
perspective because it's beginning that
that very first night yeah it's also
just a reminder of the number of teams
we have in place all over the world in
difficult situations and also you know I
thank our viewers for paying the
attention to this story that we've
wanted to give it because only because
of their interests uh that we're able to
tell these stories that's exactly what I
was thinking that's spot on you know we
have and will always be willing to leave
the comfort of the studio to cover a
story you guys have done it over the
course of your careers for a long time
but this is where we find ourselves on a
daily basis those teams we have all
around the world do a job that is not
easy and oftentimes dangerous so I'd
like to speak on behalf of all of us if
I can and just say thank you to those
teams that give us the stories that we
need to hear on a daily basis and a year
later it's still a story with no end in
sight although we heard president
zielinski say it will end in 2023. I
hope he's right about that you can only
hope I hope so